[Musique]
20 ans et plus encore Je regarde juste là-
bas en regardant
un jour à la fois ta libération conditionnelle sera
satisfaite dans quelques mois et ensuite tu
pourras recommencer
[Musique] la
vie ne va pas comme je le pensais
[Musique  ]
j'ai tellement de mal avec moi-même que je ne
sais même pas ce que je fais avec moi-même
ici tu vas devoir parler
il n'y a pas d'urgence
[Musique]
et j'ai vécu en Californie pendant près de 25
ans passerais-tu une journée  à l'océan
avec moi tu sais que tu ne peux pas ramener à la maison
des enfants abandonnés à droite Mehcad un médecin
nous connaissons ton dossier tu es toujours en
liberté conditionnelle dans le bon état de Californie
as-tu un pétrole cassé Nick aller-retour
sur un chemin
[  Musique]
désolé, il m'a fallu si longtemps pour arriver ici
[Musique]
vous